hay un montón de situaciones un montón
de ejemplos en los que estamos
estudiando una cosa muy precisa y
podemos encontrar una probabilidad
teórica exacta que ahorita vamos a ver a
qué me refiero con esto déjame lo
escribo por aquí probabilidad
y uno de los ejemplos más sencillos de
probabilidad teórica es cuando estás
tirando una moneda justa digamos que
tienes una moneda completamente justa o
sea que no está cargada y la tiras de
una forma justa entonces te va a salir
águila o sol estos son los dos posibles
resultados y va a salir alguno de estos
dos con exactamente la misma
probabilidad entonces te puedes
preguntar oye cuál es la probabilidad de
que obtengamos un sol en teoría tenemos
dos posibles resultados x probables
entonces esta probabilidad la podemos
obtener poniendo en el denominador la
cantidad de resultados x probables y
bueno el sol es uno de esos dos
resultados aquí probables así es que en
teoría la probabilidad de que al tirar
esa moneda no salga sol es un medio y
bueno sí
verdad tienes una moneda que es
completamente justa y la tiras de una
forma justa entonces en realidad está
así es la probabilidad de que salga sol
podemos hacer lo mismo pero tirando un
dado si tenemos un dado justo entonces
cada una de sus caras tiene la misma
probabilidad de salir aquí podríamos
obtener un 12
4 5 o 6 que va a salir alguna de estas
caras pero como es un dado justo la
probabilidad de obtener cada una de
estas caras es exactamente la misma así
es que si nos preguntamos cuál es la
probabilidad de que obtengamos un
resultado mayor o igual a 3
entonces como tenemos seis resultados x
probables ponemos aquí un 6 y luego
contamos cuáles de estos resultados x
probables son mayores o iguales a 3 y
esos pues son estos resultados 4
resultados y entonces la probabilidad de
que la cara que sale en el dado sea
mayor o igual a 3 es 4 sextos o dos
tercios y bueno estamos suponiendo que
es un dado justo pero bueno en este tipo
de cosas
está bien para cosas sencillas como
tirar una moneda o tirar un dado
si tienes una moneda que no sabes que es
justa pero tienes una computadora en la
mano con una hoja de cálculo que es un
programa como excel o números entonces
puedes tirar la moneda muchas veces y a
ir anotando los resultados y así
determinar cuál es la probabilidad de
que en esa moneda salga un sol pero hay
otras cosas otras situaciones que se
escapan de lo que puede llegar a hacer
con tu computadora de las cuales
realmente no puedes calcular su
probabilidad teórica aunque hay por
ejemplo el fútbol americano
digamos que quieres saber cuál es la
probabilidad de anotar cierta cantidad
de puntos pues de eso claro que no la
podemos calcular ok porque eso depende
de los seres humanos que son súper
impredecibles y cuántos puntos vamos a
anotar depende de muchísimas cosas
impredecibles depende de cómo se van a
comportar un bonche de personas cómo van
a reaccionar esas personas a otras
situaciones va a depender del clima
a alguien se podría enfermar la pelota
podría estar mojada y muchísimas cosas
hay muchísimas cosas que van a provocar
que se vaya un punto hacia un lado o se
anoten siete puntos hacia este lado o el
otro lado y por eso es que en
situaciones como esta tiene mucho más
sentido pensar en una probabilidad
experimental y con la probabilidad de
experimentar realmente lo que estamos
haciendo es estimando qué tan probable
es que algo suceda basándonos en los
datos y la experiencia que tenemos
entonces digamos que has estado poniendo
mucha atención a tu equipo a lo largo de
esta temporada ya han pasado varios
partidos y aquí tienes bastante
información de todos los partidos aunque
ahí este es una historia y en este eje
tenemos la cantidad de puntos anotados
por tu equipo de 0 a 9 10 a 19 20 a 29
30 a 39 y 40 a 49 y
y tenemos el número de partidos en los
que se anotaron esta cantidad de puntos
por ejemplo esta barra de listo grama
nos está diciendo que en dos de los
partidos anotamos entre cero y nueve
puntos en cuatro de los partidos
anotamos entre 10 y 19 puntos en cinco
de los partidos anotamos entre 20 y 29
en tres de los partidos anotamos entre
30 y 39 y en dos de los partidos
anotamos entre 40 y 49 puntos y bueno
digamos que quieres predecir algo acerca
del próximo partido de tu equipo
entonces lo primero que vamos a ver es
cuántos partidos ha jugado tu equipo
aunque aquí tenemos dos partidos y aquí
tenemos cuatro partidos
tres partidos y finalmente dos partidos
y dos más cuatro son 615 son once más
otros cinco dieciséis 16 en lo que
llevamos de la temporada tu equipo ha
jugado 16 partidos y tú quieres sacar
información acerca de qué podría pasar
en el partido número 17 partido 17
quieres saber cuál es la probabilidad de
anotar 30 puntos o más
hay que saber cuál es la probabilidad de
que tus puntos puntos sean mayores o
iguales que 30 en el partido 17 y otra
vez un partido de fútbol americano es un
sistema super complejo donde hay
muchísimas cosas que afectan la
puntuación de nuestro equipo y desde si
uno de nuestros jugadores se enfermó
cómo van a interactuar justo ese día las
personas
si alguien del público le grita algo al
core back y éste reacciona bien o
reacciona mal o que hay un partido de
fútbol es un sistema super complejo y no
podemos usar una probabilidad teórica
porque hay demasiadas variables de las
que ni siquiera estamos conscientes pero
lo que sí podemos hacer es utilizar la
probabilidad experimental aunque hay
todos estos datos que tenemos aquí y
nuestra experiencia y bueno tal vez
también echarle un vistazo a la defensa
del otro equipo y con esta información
hacer una estimación
porque la verdad es que lo que vamos a
hacer yo no me siento cómoda diciendo
que es una probabilidad en realidad es
una estimación no va a ser precisa si
repitiéramos muchísimas veces un
experimento como éste veríamos que este
tipo de estimaciones no son tan buenas
como las probabilidades teóricas pero si
nos dan algo de información aunque no
sabemos si ésta va a ser la defensa más
difícil de todo el año o la más fácil
pero bueno para hacer una estimación de
qué tan probable es que anotemos 30
puntos o más en el partido 17 pues nos
vamos a ver los 16 partidos anteriores y
podemos ver que en cinco de ellos
anotamos 30 puntos o más
de los 16 partidos que hemos jugado en
estos 5 anotamos 30 puntos o más
entonces una estimación de la
probabilidad de anotar 30 puntos son más
en el partido 17
basándonos en nuestra experiencia previa
y podríamos pensar en esto como en
probabilidad experimental sería 5 entre
16 16 porque en 5 de los 16 partidos
jugados ha sucedido esto pero hay que
tener mucho cuidado porque no podemos
andar diciendo que tenemos la seguridad
de que la probabilidad de anotar 30
puntos son menos es cinco dieciseisavos
porque aquí sólo obtenemos algunos datos
y cada equipo contra el que jugamos es
distinto el clima va a estar distinto
las personas van a estar en un humor
distinto igual y están más emocionadas
de llegar al partido 17 o están
aterradas etcétera etcétera etcétera
esta es simplemente una estimación yo
más bien diría algo así como esto ha
sido cierto 5 de las 16 veces que hemos
jugado en lugar de llamarle probabilidad
aunque sea muy impreciso sigue siendo un
indicador de lo que puede llegar a pasar
con esta estimación
podemos decir que basándonos en la
experiencia previa es más probable que
no anotemos 30 puntos o más pero siempre
hay que tomar en cuenta que nos estamos
basando en datos experimentales y bueno
a lo largo de la temporada pueden haber
cambiado muchas cosas podríamos haber
cambiado de entrenador o puede ser que
alguno de los jugadores haya crecido
tres centímetros y algún otro se haya
lastimado y haya dejado de jugar o hayan
aprendido a jugar mucho mejor aunque el
chiste es que este índice experimental
hay que tomarlo con mucha perspicacia y
aunque no sea preciso por lo menos nos
da una idea vaga de que podemos esperar
del próximo partido